this video is sponsored by nordvpn
[Music]
hey wisecrack jared here and today we're
talking about one of the funniest and
weirdest shows on television atlanta
what makes atlanta so thought provoking
is that it's simultaneously one of the
most realistic
and one of the most surreal shows on
television it's this seemingly
contradictory combination that makes the
show one of the most interesting and
hilarious shows on the air so welcome to
this wisecrack edition on the philosophy
of atlanta spoilers ahead and hey
lakeith if you're watching
this one's for you buddy but first a
quick breakdown for the uninitiated
atlanta has a simple premise earn a
princeton dropout needs to find a way to
make some money
so he links up with his cousin alfred
aka paperboy and becomes his manager
all the while he tries to balance his
relationship with the mother of his
daughter van
and becomes friends with alfred's
roommate darius but this simple premise
is deceiving as the show which creator
donald glover
described as twin peaks with rappers
pushes the boundaries of reality to
insane lengths for both comedic and
dramatic effect
and it accomplishes this by using both
surrealism and realism
let's begin by defining our terms
realism is any set of restrictions to a
creative work which demand that it
adhere to the dominant assumptions about
what
is and isn't possible realism presents
the world with minimal interference from
the perspective of the artist
one of the best examples of contemporary
realism is the work of british filmmaker
ken loach
who uses his films to present the gritty
reality of british life without any
sugarcoating
his most recent film i daniel blake
tells the story of a man struggling to
stay financially afloat in the brutal
bureaucracy of the british welfare state
and unlike the typical hollywood tale of
overcoming poverty
daniel blake dies alone in a bathroom
stall before receiving justice
unlike this harsh realism surrealism
pushes
beyond the limits of reality if ken
loach uses the camera to show the world
precisely as it
is someone like david lynch uses it to
create something which
exceeds our logical expectations
now it's also worth noting that most
comedic television is neither realist
nor
surrealist but simply fiction with no
real claimed authenticity
this is why it doesn't matter that the
manhattan of seinfeld is just a sound
stage in los angeles
or that kevin james could be married to
three different beautiful women in two
different cbs shows
now that we're clear on the basics let's
get into the nitty-gritty of surrealism
with the og surrealist andre baton who
is to surrealism what guy fieri is to
donkey
sauce represent ratan was a french
writer working in the early 20th century
who viewed surrealism as both
an artistic and political tool one of
the ways in which baton describes
surrealism is a psychic
automatism in its pure state by which
one proposes to express
the actual functioning of thought if you
haven't had your daily microdose of lsd
yet what baton is saying
is that surrealism uses art to express
what's really going on
at both the personal and social level
surrealist art might confuse us at first
but on the other side of this confusion
we can see the world in a new light
so how do you take an art form that
aspires to exceed
reality and combine it with an art form
that takes the exact opposite approach
well let's find out first on realism
atlanta makes a deliberate effort to
portray life in atlanta
accurately especially for people
struggling like earn
it removes the fictionalized glamour of
say a rap video and instead gives us the
sometimes
not so pleasant reality behind the
facade take paperboy's apartment
while the network originally wanted him
to live somewhere that would fit the
stereotype of a rapper's house
the show puts him in a pretty standard
atlanta apartment building where someone
like paperboy would
actually live or redman got my ironing
board right here
you know we ironed on the floor in here
you know it's easy
and watch tv at the same time he also is
usually profusely sweating because
atlanta is [ __ ] hot and anyone who
had portrayed otherwise with makeup is a
liar
meanwhile earn lives in a storage unit
and works a series of odd jobs while
trying to make it as a manager
when they're in need of sustenance
paperboy and darius don't just get wings
from an anonymous restaurant
they go to atlanta institution jr
crickets and order lemon pepper wet
wings
a regional staple not available outside
the 678 and 404 area codes
he made you the lemon pepper joints but
these got the sauce on them
oh snap lemon pepper wet
this commitment to realism makes the
city of atlanta a
character in the show this stands in
stark contrast to
surrealism while its realism is
important atlanta's embrace of
surrealism has produced its most
memorable moments whether it's the
nutella sandwich guy on the bus
resistance is a symptom of the way
things are
[Music]
not the way things necessarily should be
fight this sandwich
no good man a black student wearing
white face in class a strip club dj
speaking to earn yo man don't just look
at her
coca-cola t-shirt or most things darius
does
be careful it's very very cold
atlanta's world is full of seemingly
nonsensical characters and events
atlanta often blends the surreal and the
real together in the same scene
including the one we just discussed
after being told that the chef hooked
him up we see
a magical glow coming from the wings
showing the viewers from outside atlanta
precisely
how magical and revered these wings are
but often the use of surrealism can ask
us to rethink
what we take for granted in the season 1
episode nobody beats the biebs paperboy
is playing a celebrity basketball game
with the son of justin timberlake and
post malone
justin bieber while the idea of paperboy
dunking on bieber is
perfect enough on its own the real twist
comes when we see justin bieber and
he's well black what is the deal with
this
this is a clear subversion of our
expectation and while this surrealist
casting might seem confusing
it creates some wonderful comedic
moments hey you didn't get to blew the
other
brains out cool but what's most
important is that
besides being black atlanta's justin
bieber acts just like the real justin
bieber
he treats reporters and fans like i love
you justin
i know [ __ ] acts like a spoiled brat
has a huge entourage and can't
fathom the idea of anyone getting more
attention than him after acting like an
[ __ ] for much of the episode bieber
holds a press conference where he
apologizes for his behavior with a new
song
something that bieber actually did in
real life
[Music]
this surreal take on bieber's very real
behavior
leaves the audience with a crucial
question namely would his behavior be
perceived differently
if he were black black bieber would
please berton as he's used not just for
surreal humor but forces the audience to
rethink their assumptions about reality
in this case does our culture forgive
white celebrities for bad behavior while
holding celebrities of color to a
different standard
an even weirder example of surrealism
takes place in the same episode
while paperboy and earn are busy at the
celebrity basketball game darius heads
to his local gun range to let off some
stress
but his range mates get pissed when they
notice darius's target poster isn't
a human outline but instead a picture of
a dog
this raises the question who the [ __ ]
would shoot a dog target
you can't shoot dogs what are you a
psycho
but then we're forced to consider well
why would i shoot at a human target
i mean that's weird right i mean look at
that one that's just way too specific
it's also a potential nod to white
people's over-the-top obsession with
their dogs which
nobody at wisecrack can relate to nope
not not even a little bit
i did not know people like dogs this
much a use of surrealism that is quite
literally hard to see takes place in
episode eight of season one in which
earn darius and paperboy are outside the
club after strong arming the club owner
to get paid
just getting their money was a surreal
endeavor in itself but things get even
weirder once they hit the parking lot
in case you don't know what you just saw
that was an invisible car speeding
through the parking lot leaving bodies
in its wake
is this meant to be a commentary on the
absurd ways that celebrities use their
money to flex on everyone else
maybe could it be highlighting the way
in which we have become so desensitized
to violence that the only way to make it
stand out is to use an invisible car
possibly or is this atlanta at its most
twin peaks and we shouldn't look for
meaning at all
either way it's a good reminder that
surrealism doesn't always have to mean
something as often it's used to
undermine and confuse our rational
impulse to project meaning onto
everything
nice karto the flip side of this
meaningless surrealism can be seen in
one of the most uncomfortable
moments of season 1 the juneteenth party
in case you're not up on your history
juneteenth is the holiday that
celebrates the abolition of slavery in
texas
and in general the emancipation of
slaves throughout the confederacy
at the party the husband of the host
gives earn an impromptu lecture on the
importance of visiting africa
that was a pilgrimage needed to
pay my respects ask for forgiveness well
you know right i don't i really don't
wait you've never been to africa
no you gotta go man it's your motherland
what are you thinking
and predicts his ancestors via his
facial features
congo ivory coast
southeastern bantu region i don't know
this spooky thing called slavery
happened and my entire ethnic identity
was erased
and to ensure that he is the platonic
form of that white guy
he later performs a poem about the
horrors of slavery
jim crow has the name of a man
but is a ghost
i am a man but jim crow
is haunting me like in that movie
poltergeist
that's right the only white guy at the
party celebrating the end of slavery
performs a poem about slavery from the
perspective of a black man
are these slave ships and to add salt to
the rim of this
super awkward margarita the party's bar
offers
fun cocktails named after the horrors of
slavery
i have the plantation master poison
and we couldn't talk about surrealism in
atlanta without covering the most talked
about episode of season one
b-a-n the entire episode takes place
during a fictional talk show where paper
boi is being grilled by a feminist
sociologist for his lyrics rap
is chicken's coming home to roost look
my life is messed up from
y'all did okay that's black news you can
look that up well your news is
problematic [ __ ] that ain't my fault
the crown jewel of this episode is a
black teenager from atlanta that
self-identifies as a 30-year-old white
man from denver
hey excuse me what ipa do you have on
tap
hey did you see game of thrones last
night this came on the heels of the
cultural
show that was rachel dolezal and the
ensuing debate about trans-racial
identity
while the notion of a white person
self-identifying as black led to
genuine debate and consideration atlanta
asks us to consider how we feel about
the issue when it's a black teen
self-identifying as a white man
and paperboy's response is one that much
of the audience likely resonates with
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry yo this is
dumb like that
this is dumb and this might be the
ultimate genius of atlanta
as unlike other shows that have used
surreal elements to take us further away
from reality
atlanta uses surrealism to bring our
focus back to reality
by using the surreal to disrupt the
habitual way we
look at and think about certain topics
we can reconsider them
all together we see this in clark county
and his hybrid music videos slash
commercial for you who
hey a flex on a [ __ ] like this
seemingly
surreal example of a famous rapper
making a song about an artificial
chocolate beverage exposes something
that's
actually going on i.e much of art
produced in our day and age
is really just thinly veiled advertising
for we don't really need
this example resonates with the
influence of marxism on baton as a
surreal moment
leads to a socio-political critique this
use of surrealism for social critique is
what keeps atlanta in the spirit of
bratan's work
in both seasons surrealism is used to
reflect on everything from inequality to
cultural appropriation
[Music]
and it refuses to let the viewer turn
off their tv without confronting
something
real and urgent about society this might
be the most unique contribution atlanta
has made to contemporary television
in the same way that it employs
surrealism without veering into
absurdity
it also provides cultural commentary
without coming off as preachy
hi i'm brandon tartikoff chairman of nbc
entertainment
and i've got a hit idea for the new fall
season
don't do drugs there's no hope with dope
and it's this commitment to pushing the
boundaries of surrealism that gives us
one of the most
insane moments of television in recent
[Music]
memory
[Music]
before we go it's worth mentioning the
aims of bratan's surrealism in relation
to atlanta creator donald glover's
musical alter ego
childish gambino as bratan makes clear
the aim of surrealism
is not simply to create a new form of
culture it's to use art to change
culture
through revealing its true structure for
baton the world
is only very relatively in tune with
thought
meaning that much of what we perceive
isn't a true indicator of the way the
world really is
we can see this in this is america where
surreal elements are used to make a
scaling political critique of the state
of affairs in contemporary america
and if this video is any indication it
seems like glover in his creative circle
will be continuing to push the limits of
a new black surrealism for the
foreseeable future
and as always thanks for watching guys
peace now guys what can also be surreal
is finding out your computer has been
secretly hacked which is why most people
use vpns to protect their web serving
we could have used one back in the early
days of wisecrack when we were
actually hacked to get back our channel
we literally had to pay off some hackers
in bitcoin
you know my life could have been like if
i had kept that bitcoin
to keep hackers out we could have used
nordvpn
with unlimited bandwidth and double data
encryption you can surf
privately and securely from anywhere in
the world
compatible with windows mac os ios and
android
nordvpn is a great way to start taking
your internet surfing
seriously start protecting your internet
experience today with 77
off a three year plan by using code
wisecrack at nordvpn.com
wisecrack don't get hacked it's really
not fun
to grab this deal head to nordvpn.com
wisecrack or just hit the link in the
description what show do you want us to
dive into next hit us up in the comments
and as always
peace